Speaker 1: OK, for months now, the right has
been saying Joe Biden and Kamala Harris are
doing something really bad by not going to
the US Mexico border.
They should go there.
Now, there's a separate discussion to be had
about do you need to go to the border to properly
manage what's going on with undocumented immigration?
There is a separate discussion about how is
the Biden administration managing what's going
on with undocumented immigration?
Is there or is there not a crisis at the border?
What has actually changed, if anything, since
Donald Trump left office just over five months
ago?
But the point here is that Republicans have
been going crazy, saying, why won't Joe go?
Why won't Comilla go?
Here is a Republican published compilation
of why won't they go to the border?
Remember this stuff?
Speaker 2: He plans to visit the border.
You haven't been to the border.
Speaker 3: So how do you respond to that criticism
and when will that visit come?
Speaker 1: When are you going to the border?
Speaker 2: Vice president, administration
has asked.
I don't know.
I don't understand the point that you're making.
Listen.
Speaker 1: Well, Kamala Harris is now going
to be going to the border and of course, now
Republicans are completely satisfied and they
believe that they are doing the right thing
in the Biden administration.
Just kidding.
Obviously, they don't.
Now, they have shifted to why is Kamala Harris
going to the wrong part of the border?
I it I know it sounds completely ridiculous,
but this is what they've now shifted to.
And also, why is she going all of a sudden?
Well, you've been demanding it for months,
right?
So here is Republican Texas Senator Ted Cruz,
also known to many as Cancun.
Cruz saying Kamala Harris is going to the
wrong part of the border.
She's not going to see the things that she
needs to see.
Take a look at this, I think.
Speaker 4: But I got to say, even this announcement,
so she announces that they're going to El
Paso.
El Paso is a lovely city.
It is a beautiful place in Texas.
It is not also it also doesn't happen to be
the locus of the crisis.
So if you look at where the the Rio Grande
Valley is and the and for folks who aren't
from Texas, let me give you a sense.
So El Paso is on the western tip of Texas.
The Rio Grande is Valley is almost on the
southern tip of Texas.
It's 800 miles away.
To give you a sense of just how far they are,
Chicago, Illinois, is closer to Washington,
D.C. than El Paso is to McAllen.
And so she's going where where the height
of the problem is.
And let me tell you what Comilla needs to
do.
Comilla, you need to go to the Rio Grande
Valley.
Comilla, you need to go to McAllen.
Comilla, you need to go to the Donner tent
facility, which is the tent city your administration
is built.
Speaker 1: This is beyond parody.
This is how it now she's doing the thing you've
been saying she should do, but now it's no
longer the right thing.
These people cannot really be dealt with in
a serious way because of this.
All along, they said the issue was she's not
going to the border.
Well, now she is.
And it's the wrong part.
Here is Fox News reporter Peter Doocy.
Steve.
No, Peter.
Yes, Peter Doocy is the son.
Peter Doocy asking White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki why, why?
Why is this happening?
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: So about today's announcement.
Why is the vice president visiting the border
this week when earlier this month she dismissed
a trip like that, saying it would be a grand
gesture?
Speaker 5: She also said in an interview with
NBC that she would be open to going to the
border if it was an appropriate time.
She said that after she said that.
So that's important context as well.
Speaker 1: And this is just a reminder, OK,
this is just a reminder that we can't take
them seriously because they don't deserve
to be taken seriously.
As soon as you engage with them in what you
believe to be a serious matter and say, OK,
we're going to go to the border, let's figure
out what's going on there, this is what you
wanted.
Now, all of a sudden, it's it's the wrong
place.
And we now know this, that the other thing
this is why I say don't even engage.
And when when we say, oh, well, why is Joe
Biden wasting time inviting Republicans to
the White House to talk about a bill he wants
to pass?
That makes sense to me.
You're actually getting the people who if
they want to play a role in legislation, they
can you bring them to the Oval Office.
Then they say we're not going to vote for
any of this stuff.
And then you go forward and you do it on your
own.
But you say, listen, I gave them a shot.
That's one thing, because that's legislators
with this type of stuff.
Go to the border, go, OK, we're going.
Well, now it's the wrong place.
And why now in the timing is suspect.
I don't think it makes any sense to engage
with it whatsoever.
If you think it does make sense, let me know.
I see no upside whatsoever.
These people are pathetic.
They will never be satisfied.
This is the game.
It's grievance culture and outrage.
The right has made it a regular talking point
to say that the left has become about grievances.
I'm seeing that on the right, my friends,
and this is a perfect example
of it.